right now the secretary of energy
wrapping up a visit to las vegas her
trip comes as governor steve sisilak
signing a new law
boosting investments in clean energy the
i-team's david sharon spoke to her
one on one david you talked about not
only the white house's job plan
but also using nevada as a dump for
spent nuclear waste yeah so brian let's
start with those energy plans and the
laws the governor just signed
the ceo of nv energy was also at today's
event and says renewable energies like
solar hydro wind he says it's actually
cheaper for us
than traditional sources well today's
energy event comes as governor siselek
signed those two
new laws aimed at boosting clean energy
here in nevada
the new laws create two transmission
lines called the green link
that would go from northern to southern
nevada allowing our state to become sort
of an
energy hub for the west now the energy
secretary was here to tout the american
jobs plan that
infrastructure proposal that the white
house says
would do a lot of what nevada is now
doing just now on the federal level
now i asked the secretary about the
ongoing battle up at yucca mountain
about 75 miles northeast of las vegas
as a permanent nuclear waste repository
right now it's the site of the federal
government's only proposal though
there is no money in the budget for it
the secretary tells me a committee is
now working
with other communities to find a place
for all this nuclear waste
we're beginning that process now but the
bottom line for nevada
is that yucca mountain will not be a
storage place
for nuclear waste something a lot of
people are waiting to hear well right
now the state is working with the
department of energy to actually remove
weapons grade plutonium that's being
stored near the security
site now in terms of the president's
energy proposals the
a recent poll found nearly 80 percent of
nevada voters
favor all the clean energy aspects of
the president's american jobs plan which
democrats and republicans are
negotiating on
right now i'm david charns 8 news now